everybody knows that 2020 was a pretty
tough year
but to add to that there are rumblings
now that data scientist
is no longer the number one job in
america
so let's sit down and talk about what
exactly
is the state of the data science job
market in the year 2021
[Music]
hello again guys and welcome back to my
channel if this is your first time here
my name is richard and this is richard
on data
the channel where i help you break into
data science and grow your skills in the
field
so glassdoor did a survey recently and
it looks like data scientist
has indeed fallen from the number one
spot
based on factors like median base salary
job satisfaction
and job openings it's sitting at number
two behind java developer
and i get questions on here all the time
about whether or not it makes sense to
get into the field now
given general fears about it and data
analytics in general getting automated
in the future
so in this video there's a few different
things that i'm going to try to break
down for you
number one is what the overall demand
out there is looking like for data
scientists
number two is a little bit more
difficult to pin down but we're going to
try to look at what the overall
supply of data scientists out there is
expected to look like
with the general understanding that as
long as demand for data scientists
exceed supply you're going to have an
easier time getting a job
and your salary is going to be higher
i'm going to talk about trends that i
expect that we're going to see
in the recovering years following 2020
and then we're going to close with
pretty much the most fun topic
imaginable which is
of course salaries before i do that take
a moment to subscribe to my channel if
you haven't already
hit the notification bell so you never
miss an update
and then smash the like button for the
youtube algorithm
and then if you guys would be willing to
support my channel i will have links in
the description of this video to my
paypal account
as well as to crypto wallet addresses
your support is highly appreciated
alright so let's start with the demand
side of the equation
and i will say overall it looks pretty
healthy
though there are some slightly
conflicting reports
to start with this is from a report that
was done by dice
following q2 of 2020 but they found that
the demand for data scientists in 2020
increased by an average of 50 percent
across
healthcare telecommunications media and
entertainment
and the banking financial services and
insurance sectors
now i'm not necessarily familiar with
the ins and outs of
all of those different industries but i
know for sure
that we're in a world where healthcare
is going increasingly digital
and that last year telecom absolutely
boomed
all of that to say is that if an
industry is growing as a whole
there's a pretty good chance that data
science is going to flourish there
but there's more in the way of good news
now not all of these statistics were
necessarily up to date
following the full impacts of the
pandemic
but there is some seriously good
speculation from reputable sources
so a report from the royal society
that's an independent scientific academy
of the uk
and the commonwealth said that the
demand for workers with data skills
grew by 231 percent over the past five
years
then ibm projected that globally around
28
of the total jobs in 2021 would be data
science jobs
and the u.s bureau of labor statistics
believes these jobs will grow by at
least 19
by 2026 so that's all very good stuff
even the fact that there's this much
hype and positive speculation going on
can lead to organizations feeling left
out or like they'd miss the boat
if they're not getting into data science
this in turn
is going to lead to the creation of more
jobs even if with
some of those jobs you might have to be
kind of careful because they're not
necessarily
the most desirable types of data science
jobs
however i would be doing a disservice to
all of you if i communicated that
everything everywhere was all sunshine
and roses
j fang that's a silicon valley data
scientist who runs the youtube channel
data science j as well as the interview
prep newsletter
interview query did some research into
this
and the picture that he found was a
little bit different
he looked at over 10 000 data science
related interview experiences and he
found that growth in data science
interviews actually slowed down
in 2020 at a 10 growth rate compared to
a previous growth rate
closer to 80 percent that's not true
necessarily of
fang companies though and it's not true
of data engineering
either where there was a 40 increase
so to be fair he still found that data
science interviews and jobs in general
were
experiencing growth but at the same time
this seems like a much
different story from some of the other
stats out there
so how do we reconcile these things i
don't know this for sure but i do think
there's a little bit of a tech focus
with the sample he was working with
so this might not necessarily speak to
what's going on in other sectors
in things like healthcare or the
financial services industry
there's also some maturation happening
both in
and outside of tech where they either
have a bigger push towards data or
machine learning engineering
or they just call the same sort of thing
something different altogether
such as research scientists we can see
the growth
there though still looks very impressive
that's always
something you have to take into account
with these types of analyses
because some people stratify it a lot
further and they look at
all the various different types of data
jobs whereas some people just focus
on jobs with the title data scientist
and it's certainly also possible in the
short term that companies had to take a
bit more of a defensive posture
whereas before they might have been more
eager to invest in data science
last year maybe there was more fiscal
uncertainty
so a little bit less hiring though again
that is more of a short-term rather than
a long-term
sort of dynamic all in all though we
live in an era where last
year even the top tech companies
experience
massive growth in their market
capitalization and there's nothing from
a long-term
fundamental sense that i can find out
there that's super scary
demand for data science overall looks
extremely healthy to me
and while there's no question that yes
it is going to undergo some changes in
the near term
the job market for it i think is going
to continue to grow
but obviously it's not enough just to
talk about the demand side
we need to talk about the supply side
too that is
how many people out there are trying to
get into data science
besides probably you based on the fact
that you're watching this video
so for this i think one of the best
first places to look
is the number of degree programs out
there from universities
because it is well known that most data
scientists
have college degrees and according to
data scienceprograms.org
there are more than 830 separate data
science programs out there
being offered from around 500
universities around the world
so first of all unfortunately i couldn't
find any charting out there on how much
exactly this has grown over the last few
years
but i do think it's fair to assume more
universities out there
are catching on to the fact that there's
more demand for data science out in
industry
and they're going to accommodate by
creating more and more types of data
science programs plus
let's just put this into perspective it
may seem like a lot that there are 500
universities out there
offering data science programs but keep
in mind that there are 25
000 universities or so around the world
so this is only somewhere around two
percent of universities
and yes i understand it's possible to
become a data scientist with a degree
like cs
or statistics like i did in fact it's
possible to become a data scientist
with no college degree whatsoever but i
do hope this helps ground you in the
fact
it's very difficult for supply of data
scientists
to keep up with the growing demand i
couldn't find statistic
up to date following the impacts of the
pandemic
but at least as of early last year data
science jobs were staying open
five days longer on average compared to
other jobs
meaning they were harder to fail with
fewer qualified
people out there all right so now that
we've covered the actual market supply
and demand side of things
let's talk about trends that we can
probably expect to see
in 2021 and in future years now there's
a wonderful blog article in kd nuggets
that i think did a great job of breaking
some of the most important things down
so they list four different things here
and i think
all of these make a lot of sense first
thing they list is the rise of decision
intelligence
which in this context basically means
artificial intelligence
this is the trend most people are
familiar with and although it's only a
piece of the big
puzzle that is data science there's no
question
ai and machine learning are huge and
they're only going to grow
next is data stories now they make a
distinction between these
and dashboards framing these as stories
that take the viewers on a journey of
the data
and easily explain all the conclusions
that are available from the analysis
adding that the users don't need any
detailed technical knowledge
to understand these stories now speaking
personally on this one
i've seen these before in the data
science context
but not nearly enough so this one
actually kind of surprised me
next trend is the increase of cloud
services
and there's no question that over the
last year a number of organizations
developed their cloud
infrastructure so yeah there's also no
question
this is going to represent an
increasingly important domain
and skill set for data scientists in the
future
and then lastly there's branching of
data analytics
specifically they mention audio video
text customer feedback style data just
to give some examples
a lot of newer people tend to think of
data as this structured sort of thing
or you have tables with rows and columns
but it doesn't always start that way you
have all this unstructured stuff in the
universe out there which is super useful
too
obviously particularly if you're just
breaking into data science for the first
time
there's no way you can be reasonably
expected to have expertise in all of
this stuff
but even knowing that some of these
things represent emerging trends
can set you apart from others and help
you have the right types of
conversations
if i were to try to summarize these
things as succinctly as possible
again based on that article as well as
my own anecdotal experience
it would be to speculate that large
unstructured data
is going to play an increasingly
important role in the future
for that reason and for others things
like natural language processing and
cloud technologies
are going to become increasingly
important components of a data science
background as well
and then as far as machine learning and
ai those are no
fad either now let's close this video on
a fun
note which is by of course talking about
money
and obviously salaries are pretty
challenging to provide a concise
story about because they vary so much by
years of experience and geographical
location
one surprisingly good resource for
understanding data science salaries out
there
is actually the salary mega thread on
the data science subreddit
obviously this is far from any kind of
scientific sampling
but you see people on here from
different countries
different regions of the united states
different levels of experience and even
variations on job title
but as we saw at the beginning of this
video from glassdoor
here in the united states anyway the
average salary for a data scientist role
is a hundred and thirteen thousand seven
thirty
and that's not taking into account
things like title changes
so for instance say if you get promoted
from a data scientist to a senior data
scientist
you're going to be swimming in the big
bucks even more
obviously this whole discussion we've
been having in this video about supply
and demand
affects prices extensively because
if there is a high demand for something
for which there is a limited supply
the price of that thing aka your salary
must go up based on all available
evidence
demand is going to significantly outpace
supply
at least in the near term so at this
point anyway
i think the future for salaries looks
absolutely fantastic
so overall just to summarize everything
that we've talked about here
i really do think the trend is your
friend until the end when it bends
data science will definitely not look
the same a few years from now
especially as emerging trends mature and
platforms like automl
become more mainstream which is going to
allow data scientists to do
more better different things i'll put
out a video soon on the trends
surrounding data engineering
and i also did a video around a year ago
where i discussed the notion of data
science becoming automated
and why i think that's overblown i'll
have a link to that in the description
but overall data science has been an
amazing trend
for years and yes 2020 was a pretty
rough year
but i don't see it as being bad enough
to where it's fundamentally going to
change that trend
data science remains lucrative and as
economies around the world
grow and continue to open up in the
coming years
i think it's only going to become even
more lucrative
so thanks for watching this video tell
me in the comments what you think
do you agree with me do you disagree
with me
then also smash the like button and i'll
see you all in the not so distant future
until then richard on data